- On this episode, Beth Comstock,
and her incredible new book are here.
I think you're gonna love this episode.
(upbeat hip music)
Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
This is episode 291 of
the Ask Gary Vee Show,
I'm super excited about this.
We have somebody who I've
gotten to know very well
in my professional career
in the last decade or so.
Somebody I admire quite a bit from afar,
and really, really interestingly,
and this is fun for me to say,
and it's fun for me to
say with you in the room,
I think I'm starting to get on this kick
of saying nicer, saying things I believe
that are nice about people to them,
because I don't think we do that.
- Oh, that's nice.
- You'll like this one, I think, Beth.
I admire you so much
through the eyes of others.
It's amazing, because of
the circles we run in,
even entrepreneurially, and
author, and personalities,
and corporate collide into
people that we both know.
There's a lot of people that we both know.
A lot of them, I'll
meet for the first time,
or things of that nature,
however it gets brought up,
over the last five or six years,
the one thing I've noticed is
the way people talk about
you behind your back
with no vested interest is awesome.
It's like, I so dream about
that's what's happening with me.
And so maybe that's why I take note.
- [Beth] Wow, that's nice to hear.
- But you're at the top, if people,
if I came out with a list of like,
top people rankings that
are having nice things
said about them behind their back,
with no vested interest.
'Cause people say nice things about people
but it's a move, and I can't be tricked,
so I know when that's happening.
A lot, thus...
It makes me like you even more
than I like you by myself.
Because I know it's consistent
regardless of the scenario,
so that's the intro I want to say.
You've got a new book, I didn't ask you,
coming out, out, what?
- Coming out.
- Coming out...
- So it's coming out
Tuesday, September 18th.
- Amazing, so here we are.
- And thank you for the blurb.
- Thank you for asking me.
I was super flattered.
We're gonna get into it in a minute.
So, Beth Comstock is, in my opinion,
a dynamic force in communication,
executives, and just human.
I'm gonna let her do her...
- Glad you added that part.
(laughing)
- Beth, if this was the, you
know, if this was comic book
number one.
Who are you?
And I'm talking like I was born, like...
Who are, what is your, give
me three, four minute...
I love context.
I think it frames up everything
and I'd like to get three,
four minutes out of you
on like who you are.
Like, from coast to coast.
- Yeah.
Well I like that.
You know, I was born 'cause
I grew up in a small town
in Virginia and my parents
came from West Virginia.
So, you know, we talked
with a southern accent.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So that was the upbringing of...
- Like a West Virginia accent is real.
- Yeah.
No, my great uncle started
a newspaper franchise
in West Virginia called the
West Virginia Hillbilly.
So I have real deep hillbilly roots.
- [Gary] That excites me.
- So, there you go.
So...
But I grew up in Virginia.
- [Gary] Yep.
- My parents moved there.
Small town as I said, small town girl.
It was a great place to grow up.
I mean it was nurturing,
my dad was a dentist.
My mom was a schoolteacher.
- [Gary] It was real good.
- It was a...
I have a brother and a sister
and that was my world.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Yet I felt like I
wanted to see the world.
- Did you read a lot?
- I read a ton.
- So it's interesting.
You know, like, it's
funny why I ask questions.
I'm so fascinated by communication.
I'm aware that you're not 19
but you're also not 91
so you're painting...
- [Beth] Somewhere in the middle.
- Right.
You're painting this picture
for me and I'm like, okay.
A woman of that generation
in that scenario
is it born in you?
You're intuitively like
I'm a big city girl
or was it reading?
Or a TV, if you said literally
I would've said to you,
"Did you watch the news a lot?
Like, did you think
Walter Cronkite was cool?"
Like, to me I'm fascinated by that stuff.
So go ahead.
- Yeah, no, I think
that's a good question.
I mean it was two things for me.
I think it was reading.
I spent every summer like
just devouring books.
You know, I loved every,
I loved fiction like crazy
and then for me it was geography.
I loved school but I remember fifth grade
like I would get so
excited about geography.
I just...
- Like filling in the map?
- The map but like who are those people?
And I've recently joined the
National Geographic board
and I'm so excited 'cause it's
like that fifth grader again.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- So, that I think instilled in me,
there's this whole world out there
and what is it?
And my family didn't travel a lot.
I mean we drove everywhere.
I think I didn't get on
a airplane until I was,
until I graduated from high school.
That was my first trip.
- Were you scared?
- I was scared.
My mother was a school teacher, as I said,
and she took me on a
teacher-sponsored trip to Europe
and it was my first flight and I was 18
and we could drink then and I ordered
a double gin and tonic.
- Yes.
- And my mother was like...
- What the hell are you doing?
- Yeah.
She was like (gasping).
I think she was just shocked
'cause I knew how to order a double.
- Double gin, yeah.
All my reading helps.
- So I remember.
(laughing)
Exactly.
I remember that flight very well.
- That's so cool.
Okay.
So, what happens?
You're a great student.
- Great student.
I went to school in my home state,
College of William and Mary.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Funny, I just found this
notebook from when I was 14,
I found my autobiography when I was 14.
- [Gary] No way.
- There was not a lot to be
excited about when I was 14.
- Did you take pictures of
that and put it on Instagram.
- I haven't put it yet
but I took a, I will.
- [Gary] You have to
social media that out.
- I will.
I will.
It was really fun to see.
- [Gary] That's real shit.
- Yeah, it's fun.
But, what I said in 14, my autography
is I'm ambitious, I wanna be
50 different things in my life,
and I said I wanna see the world.
So even at 14, I had that sense.
- Wow.
The 14 of yours, the 14 year
old version of you nailed it.
- Yeah. It was amazing.
- [Gary] No, you really nailed it.
- Yeah, yeah.
Although I did I say I wanted
to be a lawyer at one point
in those 50 things.
That must've been one day.
- We've all done that.
I think I said astronaut at one point.
- Did you ever wanna be a lawyer? No.
- I know I wanted to be...
I've only found one thing ever
that showed me.
My whole life, I thought I wanted to be,
you know, a businessman,
'cause it really was early for me.
So I was like, yeah.
But I was devastated.
I found a picture of me in kindergarten
and said I wanted to be a cowboy.
(laughing)
And I was like, fuck.
- But didn't you maybe
grow up to be a cowboy?
- Hey, listen.
This is how interpretations are fun.
Okay.
Very cool.
So, you went to school.
Then what happens?
- Then I go to school.
I studied biology.
Thought I was gonna go to medical school.
- [Gary] Okay.
- But what I really wanted to do
is I got into it was I wanted
to be a science reporter.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- So, because I was a biology major
I tried to take more
writing classes and they...
- Were you like really into TV?
- I was into TV but I
wanted to just report
and so...
- But, but...
You wanted to report on TV.
- I did wanna report on TV.
- So there's a fun dynamic there.
Knowing now enough about you
Monday Morning quarterbacking
calms, communication...
Like, that's an interesting part
'cause I think some people may,
like default into vanity
and I default into scale.
Go ahead.
- Yeah, I just, I mean to me that,
'cause I grew up watching TV.
I was a kid of TV.
But, my first job was my last year in...
- Real quick and I apologize.
What was your favorite TV
show as a kid you think?
- Oh gosh.
There were so many.
- Rattle off a few 'cause this will be fun
for me personally.
This is me just having fun.
- Well I was a kid who watched
reruns after school everyday.
- [Gary] Yes, me too.
- So these were, you know,
like I Dream of Genie.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Gilligan's Island.
I don't know, like they're
all from the 50s and 60s.
- No I watched both of those shows.
- I loved those shows.
The Brady Bunch.
I mean, all those kind
of things, I loved those.
- My core thing coming
after school reruns,
Three's Company,
The Facts of Life.
(laughing)
- No, I hated that one.
- Yes. Oh god, The Facts
of Life was so good.
- Charlotte Rae and that.
Oh I hated that.
Tootie, was it Tootie?
- Okay, you're really a good TV person.
This might divul...
Beth, we better stay focused here
'cause this might turn
into an entire podcast
of TV trivia.
- [Beth] I don't know. You might win.
- I literally was about to say Tootie.
I think Charlotte Rae just passed away.
- I think she did, yeah.
She was a good character.
- So you wanted to be a science reporter.
- So I wanted to be a science reporter.
- Mrs. Garrett for everybody out there.
That was the character.
- [Beth] But, so my first...
- Real quick, Beth.
I'm sorry, I'm very helter skelter.
I know everyone's mad at me.
Do you know that Mrs.
Garrett first appeared on
Diff'rent Strokes and that
spun off The Facts of Life?
- No, I didn't know that.
- [Gary] Bam.
- I didn't know that.
- Just step it up here.
All right, go ahead.
(laughing)
- So, yeah.
And then my first job was
I was a senior in college
and I worked in public radio.
I worked in the local public radio station
in Norfolk Virginia and I
remember going home to my hometown
and spending a day with
the migrant apple pickers
and they were singing beautiful songs
as they picked their apples
and I was just smitten.
I wanted to be a storyteller.
- [Gary] Wow.
- So then I tried to work my way
and I had no confidence.
So, my first job I went to work
covering the Virginia House of Delegates
for like C-Span of Virginia in the day.
And I did everything.
I worked behind the camera.
I learned to register camera.
I learned to edit, I was
in front of the camera.
I was like a Jackie of all trades.
And I tried to get my first job...
- I apologize real quick.
Team, I need a Jackie of
all trades t-shirt made.
I'm not kidding.
(laughing)
Right now.
This is gonna be the most meta thing ever
because I'm gonna wear this in
four months like on a flight,
somebody's gonna see it and
they're gonna be blown away
that it exists.
I'm not kidding.
Make a note Caleb.
I want a Jackie of all
trades t-shirt made.
I want somebody to draw it.
We have that skill.
Get Caesar on it right now.
He's gonna kill it.
I want a Jackie of all trades t-shirt made
and I'm going to wear it.
- I wanna see that.
- Let's get one for Beth.
- [Beth] I would like one too.
- And Molly too.
Three.
And I'm not kidding.
I want it to be rare
'cause I'm gonna sell mine
on eBay one day.
Three t-shirts, Jackie of all trades.
Molly, Beth, me.
- [Man] Jackie, J-A-C...
- J-A-C-K-I-E I think.
I don't know.
You know, Jack of all trades?
I was the Jackie of all trades.
- Jackie of all trades
t-shirt, women's cut for them.
Look, you know, these
are gonna be premium.
- Yeah, no bulk, no bulky thing.
No bulky.
- You want a men's cut?
- [Molly] Yeah of course.
- Okay, you want women's?
- No, I like. I want women's cut. Yeah.
- Okay.
Two...
Get sizes.
(laughing)
You know what I love about this?
Somebody's gonna see
your name on the podcast
and they're gonna get, like
people that don't follow me,
they're gonna see that and be like,
"I wanna listen to that,"
and they're gonna be like,
they definitely didn't
think that Mrs. Garrett
from The Facts of Life
and a Jackie of all trades
t-shirt conversation
would be going on.
- [Beth] No, I didn't either.
- This is not necessarily
the format that is...
Okay, go ahead Beth.
- No, so one story about trying
to make it as a TV reporter
was I lacked confidence.
- [Gary] Yes.
- But I also had a
resilience at the same time.
So I was working in Richmond Virginia
and I finally had a tape,
'cause as Jackie of all trades
I did get to make a
tape every now and then
and I got to interview a few members
of the House of Delegates.
So I made it a thing to send my tape
to the local TV station,
it was channel 12 Richmond Virginia.
- [Gary] Love her.
- And the news director
would never take my call.
He would never do anything
but I called everyday.
I called everyday at about lunch time.
I would call him.
- [Gary] Love.
- And finally after about
four or six months he said,
he finally picked up
the phone and he goes,
"Listen.
I'm never gonna hire you.
You look too young.
You have no experience.
Why would I ever hire someone
who looks as young as you?
Really?
You're not gonna make
it in this business."
And I was devastated but
after that I was speechless.
I had never had anyone speak at like but,
after that it was like this
sort of anger grew up in me
and I was like, you don't know me.
- Did you say that or did he hang up?
- He hung up and I hung up.
I was in shock.
- I get it. I get it.
Look at me.
I'm a character and I've
had those kind of moments.
So I get that.
So you hang up and you went quickly...
I'm very curious about
this question, Beth.
Did you go sad for the day? For lunch?
For a week? For a month?
Or did you literally go sad
to that place in your head?
- No, I went sad for a couple of days.
Probably weeks even 'cause
I had like sucked my thumb.
- [Gary] This is important.
- Again, I didn't have a lot of confidence
and I was like, well this guy says
I'm never gonna make it.
- Do you know the guy's name?
- I ended up calling
him Mr. Rant in my head.
I'm sure I could go
back and find his name.
- You don't know his name?
Can we find his name?
- I would have to do some sleuthing.
- Can we find him?
- Yeah. I don't know.
- Team?
- [Woman] We'll find him.
- Thank you.
Go ahead.
- But Mr. Rant is what I called him
and it just grew in me
like, he doesn't know me.
He doesn't define me.
And so that always was pivotal to me
because this kind of rebel,
this resilience like, I gotta show you.
- Look, this is a really
interesting time to say something.
Beth and I have a really
nice professional...
We're both so busy and da da da da.
It's really interesting.
Literally as you're telling this story,
this specific piece, I'm
like, "And that's that."
Like literally, up until
this moment, you're kind.
Think about how I introduced this.
Literally until this second,
like literally now I'm like,
oh this is why we still...
I have met many executives.
There's lots of executives.
Like this kinship towards you
that I've never really fully,
I've actually up until four seconds ago
always leaned on kind.
This, you being pissed the fuck off.
- I have a few people you should talk to.
(laughing)
- That's fine.
But, I understand the mac...
I'm sure plenty of people,
you know, the macro,
is the macro.
This thing is the thing.
- Yeah.
But I mean, you're making
me remember that whole time
of just trying to get started in a career.
From there, I sort of worked in network.
My dad was helping me try
to like get people he knew
and we were small town.
He did two interesting things.
One, when I was still in
college he had a patient
who he was a dentist and he had a patient
who was a CBS news producer in Washington,
which was about two hours away.
I'm sure he got him in this like lock hold
with like his molar, like
threatening to pull it out.
And he's like,
"My daughter wants to get into television.
What can you do for her?"
And this guy said,
"Well I work with then Diane Sawyer."
Who was a young...
(blowing raspberries)
A young reporter at the state department,
not the Diane Sawyer she came to be.
- Did you know who that was at that point?
- I think barely,
honestly, I really didn't.
And so I got to go and shadow her a day
at the state department.
- Get the fuck out of here.
- Yeah.
And she was so incredibly,
she was just starting out.
She had just gotten back
from Chad or something.
But, I would look for
those little moments.
It was just a fluke thing.
- Jump in here.
You know, this is how I helter skelter.
And then of course you've
gotten, you've met her...
- [Beth] No, this is...
- Hold on.
Real quick 'cause this is
getting more fun by the second.
You so threw me for a loop.
Are you telling me in the last 20 years
you've never run into Diane Sawyer?
- I have but I've never said hi to her.
- You are...
(laughing)
Call Diane Sawyer right now.
Guys...
Beth, this is...
- [Beth] No, it's embarrassing.
- Real quick, real quick.
Team, clip this.
Give it to me.
I'm tweeting at Diane...
This is gonna be huge.
You've seen her at
events or non-profits...
- 'Cause I grew up in media.
I worked at...
- I got it. I got it.
I got it.
- I never worked at ABC.
- This is amazing.
- I did work at CBS.
I worked at NBC.
I worked at CNN.
- Wait, Beth help me here
'cause this is getting more fun.
Beth, how many times have you
been in a physical same room
or conference as Diane Sawyer?
Tell the truth right now.
How many times?
Give me the real number.
- I've been in a conference
with her at least
probably two or three times
and once I had this sense
that I was gonna go say,
remember you would not remember this
but you made a big impression
on me and I lost my nerve.
- You would've made her...
Do you understand?
- No, I don't know.
I was so...
- No I'm saving you time.
You would've made,
Beth you are such an all-time
accomplished executive.
I understand. I got it.
But you're not a dummy
meaning you're aware
of what you've accomplished.
You would make...
I basically think I'm
living my life right now
trying to do as much for
all these young people
on one thesis.
In 29 years, some crazy successful people
are gonna roll up on me and be like,
one tweet you made.
Like, I can't wait for Beth
Comstock to come up to me
and say, you made...
Beth, this is crazy.
- I know.
I know, well I didn't see her,
I saw her like mid-career, let's say.
But I was just, I've like...
I don't know.
I was just like, what do I say?
Like, hey, you...
- You say,
"Hey Diane Sawyer.
Do you remember in 19-something,
I shadowed you."
And, I think the biggest
question is, you're right.
Your point.
She'll probably not remember.
- No way she would remember.
- Or she might because,
like here's where life's awesome.
You might've said something weird.
- I didn't.
(laughing)
- Fair enough.
'Cause you didn't say anything?
- No.
I was such a good girl.
- No, when I say weird.
I apologize. I use funny slang.
I use words in not the right way.
You might've said something
that caught her attention
or started a thought or maybe that day
later at home something
happened that made you remember.
Maybe you were wearing blue shoes
and something with blue...
- [Beth] Yeah, maybe.
- You know you now have to do this, right?
- Yeah, I do.
- You know the cat's out of the bag.
- You know that...
How many people are
watching live on Facebook?
- [Man] Like 350.
- Good.
Can the 350 people on Facebook right now
tweet both Beth Comstock and Diane Sawyer
and tell them what's going on right now?
Thank you.
- But she had great advice
for me when I met her.
- [Gary] Is that true?
- Yeah.
She said, 'cause I was
like, I wanna be a reporter.
And she said,
"Well, here's what I want you to do."
I still remember 'cause this is impact
people like you have on young people.
- [Gary] Keep going.
- And so she was like,
my brother was graduated
from high school that night
and she said,
"Okay, here's what I
want you to do tonight
when your brother's graduating.
You have to have perspective.
You can't go and think it's your brother.
You have to assume he's not your brother.
What's he doing there?
What story are you telling?"
And again, like that two hour session
just meant the world to me.
- [Gary] That was awesome.
- Yeah, so...
And I never...
But that was a pattern for me.
- [Gary] Good news.
We fixed it.
- [Beth] Yeah, we did fix it.
- It's gonna happen right now.
Let's keep fixing.
Go ahead. Tell me more on this pattern.
Get cozy, Beth.
- Well no, I mean this
one I put in the book
in the sense that I shared a
very similar version of this
when I worked at CNN for a year.
- You worked at CNN for a year?
- [Beth] I worked at CNN for two years.
- What years?
- It would've been early 90s
and it was during the
first Gulf War, CNN...
- That's, like for all the youngsters,
that is the moment.
CNN became CNN during the first Gulf War
because it was 24/7, full access.
It was almost the closest
thing I could tell you
to the internet.
It was a 24...
- Thank you for being my
generation translator.
- Yeah.
I'm trying to help these kids.
(Beth laughing)
- But, so Ted Turner who was at his day
the swashbuckling Steve Jobs
of the media world at that day.
They disrupted traditional media.
And, I did PR on occasion for him
and I worked there for a year
and he didn't know my name.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And so I decided I was
gonna change all that.
And, I finally got up my nerve.
- Chips on shoulders.
- So, unlike Diane Sawyer
where I never said hello
I finally got up my nerve
and I picked the worst time possible.
I saw him going into the men's room.
We were at the U.N.
- Flat out.
- He was getting an award.
He goes into the men's room
and I go now's my chance.
(laughing)
As one does.
And so he's coming out of the men's room
and there I am.
And I'm like,
"Hi, Ted."
And he goes, "Oh hi."
In his southern accent and he
gives me this incredibly wet.
- Wet.
- Slimy handshake.
- [Gary] Yes. Keep going.
- And he kinda looked at me like,
what do you gotta say and I froze.
I kinda looked down and he walked away
and he zipped up his fly
and he never knew my name.
But it was that moment where
I just said to myself like,
you did it.
Like, I didn't care.
- You were pumped?
- I said hi to him.
- [Gary] You were pumped.
- I was pumped.
- [Gary] I love this.
- I was no longer like,
I stepped away from the wallflower.
I said hi.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I gave myself
permission to get in there.
- Now I really wanna
help people in the world,
not kidding.
How old were you when this happened?
- I was 30.
- This is important.
This is super important.
I talk a lot about lately 18, 22, and 30.
- [Beth] How interesting.
- Yeah, these are three...
It's funny, these three ages
are really playing with me.
People are putting
disproportionate pressure
on themselves at these
points in their lives
when we're still remarkably young.
You are like a big deal to a lot of people
and for them to hear a
story that you were thrilled
that you were awkwardly
saying hello to somebody
and that was the net accomplishment.
There was no next conversation.
There was no he heard something
profound from you and...
- He didn't even know my name.
- I hear it.
It's unbeli...
Let me tell you about me at 30.
I was packing boxes in a liquor store
at 11:30 at night on December 21st
'cause I wanted to get packages out
for people the next day.
This needs to be talked about Beth.
- It does.
Why say 18 and 22?
What's going on then?
- I'm just looking at a lot of my feed.
You know, I listen a lot.
There's a anxiety at 18, 22, and 30
that is remarkably high to me.
18, I think you're making
that transition into college.
22, you're making that or,
even if you're not going to college
you think you should be or this and that.
They're just watershed moments.
They're transition of graduation.
Because regardless,
depending on who you are,
you've decided you're a grown
up in all three of those ages
different than other numbers.
18, you're a grown up.
I guess 21 could throw it,
but 18, 22, I'm a grown up.
30, holy shit. I don't
have my shit together.
I'm a grown up.
Those three are playing with me.
I'm packing boxes in a liquor store.
Packing, I'm in the warehouse.
You are thrilled that you...
This is important Beth.
Because people think they
have to have everything
figured out at 29.
- No, you don't at all.
- And you know what's happening?
Bad behavior.
- [Beth] Yeah.
- Things that lead to depression,
things that lead to substance abuse,
things that lead to bad relationships,
things that lead to,
do you know how many,
Beth, do you know how many people
maxed out their credit cards
to buy Bitcoin at 15,000?
- [Beth] No, I would...
- I'll tell you.
A ton of people, so I'd go from,
you know, you saw what happened.
- [Beth] Yeah.
- And they bought at the
top with credit cards
'cause experts 100,000.
- [Beth] Everybody was saying
you have to do this, yeah.
- And now I'm getting
the emails 'cause I'm me.
- [Beth] Oh my gosh, that's horrible.
- They're, do you know
what paying 12% interest
on 100,000 on a thing that's under water?
Like, why did they do that?
Because they wanna buy a plane.
'Cause they wanna be successful.
So anyway, I don't know.
I'm sorry, this is the
purpose of this format
for different stories.
This is powerful to me.
Maybe I'm reacting to it.
You, at 30, just happy to say hello.
- Yeah.
And I bring it up
because it is that moment
where you're pushing
yourself to do something
you're not comfortable with.
- [Gary] Yes.
- As a reserved, shy person
I realized I was standing
in my own way too.
You know?
I mean, I would go to meetings
and people didn't know
who I was.
I'd worked for this guy for a year
and he didn't know who I was.
I mean it wasn't like, I
wasn't in his office everyday,
but...
- You were in the mix.
- I was in the mix.
But yet I wasn't taking advantage of it
and so there were those
moment when you gotta say,
I'm holding myself back.
And that was one of those moments for me.
Words, you know, you're
grabbing your own agency.
Like, I gotta do this.
- Good for you.
And then the momentum built.
- And then momentum built from there.
And, you know, I've used that approach
to getting over introversion.
You know, I'm really
the life of the party.
I accept that.
And I go to a event and
everybody's meeting,
"Hey, I'm..." you know.
And I'm the first one
over by the chip bowl
or at the back of the room
and that's another place
where I've had to say, okay.
I'm gonna go meet one person.
Like, I would never probably
have come and met you.
But I would go find somebody else
who looked like they
were okay talking to me
and you just, then the
next time it's two people.
Then the next time, then I'd say like,
now I'm gonna go talk to Gary Vee.
But that's after, it's
behavior modification.
It's after 10 times, I'm
finally the confidence
and less awkward to do that.
- I love this.
Real quick 'cause now
I'll speed up a little bit
'cause I wanna get to the book
and I wanna answer a couple questions.
So, from CNN, now speed
up the episode one.
- So I worked in a couple different...
I worked at CBS and I came back to NBC
and NBC, I worked at NBC News.
It was a formative job for me.
I loved that job.
It was one of the best jobs ever.
The news division had
undergone a real issue
that they almost blew up
the whole news division
because of a scandal.
- [Gary] Oh really?
- And for me it was one of my most,
what I loved about it was entrepreneurial.
And I think that was my awakening
that you can be an
entrepreneur in a big company.
- [Gary] Good.
- And really kinda created a path for me.
And then, I worked my way through NBC.
Ended up going to GE.
I got a call one day from Jack Welch.
- What was the last job you had at NBC?
- Well, I went to GE,
came back a couple times.
My last job was I led digital media at NBC
and I oversaw ad sales and then news stuff
and new things were iVillage and Hulu.
So, we had one that didn't go so well
and one that went really well.
- Keep going.
Then Jack...
- And then, I well...
Before that, I got on the GE radar
and Jack Welch called me up to
his office one day and said,
"I want you to come and work at GE."
That was the last thing from my mind.
- Sure.
- I was gonna be in media my whole life.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Why would I go to GE?
- [Gary] Definitely not.
- And, I mean he was on his
way up to Jack Welch the icon
but at that point he hadn't
quite hit the big time.
- But he was...
- He was CEO and he had said he was gonna,
it was important, the
company was doing well,
but he was gonna retire in four years
and in that four years I worked with him
he really sorta became
superstar CEO of his day.
And I learned a lot from
that opportunity but,
what I'd say from that
is I didn't think I,
why would I go to GE?
GE owned NBC but there was
just something I felt I had,
it was an opportunity.
I could see the world.
I could learn something new.
- Was the see the world
the big one for you?
- I think the see the world was it.
I think that was it and I
remember standing by the elevator
after I had announced I was going to GE
and one of my NBC colleagues was like,
"You know they sell light bulbs, right?"
Like, you're leaving NBC
to go sell light bulbs?
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah. I get it.
- And I was like, "Yeah
and I'm excited about it."
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I didn't know why but that's always
I guess a theme for me.
I kind of pick these things.
Anyway, and so from there
I just spent the bulk
of my career doing marketing
and innovation work at GE.
Seeding businesses, pushing for change,
and that became my thing.
- It's really cool.
What's the book about?
- The book's about pushing for change.
(Gary laughing)
I'm pretty consistent.
And what I tried to do with the book is
make it very personal and share
stories early to mid-career.
I'm really trying to reach
people early to mid-career
to say, you know, we've
all had to start somewhere
and you just gotta get outta your way
and don't ask permission
or give yourself permission
and try to make change happen.
I try to highlight the bad behavior
that we all have to deal with at work
when people wanna make change happen.
And share my stories of
things that didn't work,
things that worked.
So that's what I'm trying to do with it.
Hopefully, inspire with the story.
Give people practical tools
and we intentionally called it
Imagine it Forward.
It's about how we need people
to fight for the future
of our companies and make change happen.
- I love it.
Andy, give us a quick question.
Since it is the Ask Gary Vee Show.
- [Andy] Quick question.
Hi, Gary.
You and Beth talk about
execution, creativity,
taking risks, et cetera.
How do we make sure our future generations
inherently learn that
failure is a stepping stone?
Since our education system lacks,
education infrastructure
lacks teaching us that?
- Your thoughts?
- I love that question.
I would've written that
question if I could have.
And that's why the cover
of my book has this
wad of rainbow paper.
Because it is about, there
is a failure message here.
And I love this question
because we're not doing that.
I worry just deeply about
how we're educating our kids.
You talk to any high school
teacher, college professor,
they'll tell you people,
students are anxious about
not knowing the answer,
or about having to be perfect.
So I don't, how are you
raising your kids that way?
I try to instill in my kids creativity,
taking risks, as much as I could.
I'm sure I wasn't perfect but I feel like
we don't do enough of
that in our school system.
- I mean, I genuinely
believe I'm the poster child
in the other direction.
I'm literally making videos...
- [Beth] Making your kids code everyday?
- Well, no, no, no.
I mean, my kids, they're nine and six.
So I got a little ways to go
but I'll get to that in a minute.
I'm literally making
content on the internet
that says fail on purpose.
- [Beth] Yeah, yeah.
- Like I literally make
content everyday that says
the reason I'm successful
is 'cause I failed
my whole life.
I was a terrible student.
I was told that I wasn't gonna be good.
Like, nothing pointed to my success
in the system I was playing in
except for me and my mom and in my head.
So like I shit on eighth place trophies.
I hate, I just posted a video...
- [Beth] Yeah, you do.
- I literally posted a video this morning
that I knew wasn't gonna do well
called Fake Environments
and left a comment
and said, I knew this wasn't gonna do well
'cause none of you wanna
deal with this reality
that if your parents
pay just for your Uber,
you're already living
in a fake environment.
Like, I'm pushing.
I'm about to get really unpopular
because I'm gonna write a parenting book
that's gonna make every
single parent in America
not like me.
So, I'm very passionate about this.
And so what am I gonna do?
- What do we do?
- Let me give you an example of what I do.
I tell a five year old boy that
he's not gonna be in the NBA
when he looks at me and
says he's going to be.
- Yeah.
- Which then is going
to create a reaction.
Maybe he is.
I don't know.
But what I'll tell you
is it's highly unlikely.
- [Beth] Yeah. Yeah.
- Because I'm not giving him that DNA.
- Yeah, but or it does create
this resiliency, right?
It's the no, not yet stuff that I love.
- [Gary] But I'm definitely not gonna say,
"You sure are little guy."
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
- [Man] I wish somebody did that for me.
- Somebody did what for you?
- [Man] I wish somebody said
that to me when I was seven
saying that.
- Because you thought.
- [Man] Yeah, when I was 18.
- Look as a parent.
- You were a solid player too.
- You're good?
- And you could see it
'cause when he plays with us
or the couple of times I've seen him play
he's rusty but you can see it's there.
But, the fact that this
fucking kid who I've...
If you knew the story of how
this man is sitting here,
right?
And saying like how he,
what he did to be here,
meaning I gave a talk at Babson,
how he kept reaching out.
I challenged him by letting
him commute for no money
to Wine Library for a year?
- But you know, there
are a couple people here
who are like that, have that story, right?
- There's a lot of people.
- Is that kind of your hiring method?
- We do a lot of different
things but obviously
these are my favorites.
This kid had the ability to make no money
and travel to New Jersey from New York
to work at a liquor store.
Like, there's a million things.
But, the fact that I know
all these things about him
that I think are remarkable
and the fact that he was
that fucking delusional at 18
that he thought he was
gonna be a basketball player
speaks to the power of fake environments.
- [Beth] Yeah, yeah.
- The fact that he spoke up.
Like and said like...
It's a big deal.
- A couple of things to add to that.
I think we need to put our
kids and our colleagues
in situations that they
gotta figure it out.
I used to have this fantasy
that we would create a class
at GE where I would send
people to, I don't know, Akron,
and we'd take their
cell phone away and say,
you gotta figure your
way back to New York.
Like, how do you do that, right?
- I would dominate.
I would dominate that kind of shit.
- 'Cause we gotta, and with our kids too.
We can't have 'em have all the answers.
- There's a lot of people here that like,
that's what I do to my team.
I don't talk to Andy.
Andy runs my team.
I don't even talk to him.
Andy, do I talk to you?
- [Andy] No.
(laughing)
- But that's the future.
How do you figure it out?
- [Andy] And it's difficult.
That makes it difficult.
- It makes it difficult
because he doesn't talk to you?
(laughing)
- Well, no because he talks.
Yeah, because I have to lose
and when on my own and learn.
- [Beth] Yeah.
- And then if Gary doesn't like something
I'll hear about it.
- You'll hear about it.
But that's also the candor
that you need, right?
- And I'm super, like I deliver
Benadryl with like honey
in and honey out, right?
Like the way I manage is like, look.
Let's put this into context first.
I fucking love you and can
not believe what you're doing.
Now real quick.
What the fuck were you
thinking about that dumb shit?
And then I'm like,
and by the way, you're fucking killing it.
Let's keep going. Right?
I'm doop, boop, boop.
Because that's the truth.
- Yeah, it's the truth.
But the failure thing you mentioned,
you're putting it out
there but, what is it?
We like have this fail fast, fail small.
Like, no one really,
you can't just fail fast
and fail small.
You have to take real risk.
And I worry that people...
- [Gary] Oh, that's to
your point. Keep going.
- I know, it's just people aren't willing
to take risk these days.
- Beth, because we're living
in one, big fake environment
right now.
We bailed ourselves...
We should just be coming
out of a depression.
Let's really play.
Let's talk about America.
I don't wanna speak...
This is where I really know
the answer to your question
or your statement.
We should just be coming
out of a recession,
a deep recession.
We bailed ourselves out.
The last seven to 10
years, this is my world now
and you're close to it
'cause you're a leader
from a corporate world
which is start up culture
is where I'm going.
Beth, we're still in the midst of a world
where somebody goes to
a liberal arts school,
is wired into the ecosystem of wealth,
pops out, never sold a
thing or has a business bone
in their body...
- And gets funded.
(Gary laughing)
- You're too smart for me.
You didn't let me build it up.
Literally comes up with an idea.
Not only do they get funded.
It's worth four million dollars.
You're 22 years old.
You thought of something.
999,000 billion quadrillion out of,
almost every time it's a bad idea
but it is now worth four million dollars
and people that are fancy and smart
and Beth and Gary Vee
give you money to go...
I mean, we are in a fake, fuck...
This is why I have, look you know,
I mean you're busy but like,
I've evolved quite a
bit through the years.
- Yeah.
No, you really have.
It's been great to see.
- At the height of my
career in Silicon Valley,
I started an agency.
Let's start there before
even my evolution.
Actions.
2009.
I have all the leverage.
And I go start a client service business.
All my Silicon Valley friends are,
what's the matter with you?
You wanna talk about light bulbs?
They're like, you could
raise 100 billion dollars
and make, what are you doing?
To go make tweets for Linda Boff at GE.
Like, this is what was
going on in the backdrop.
I just wanted to be practical.
I just didn't want a fake environment.
I just wanted to operate.
- Yeah.
I like the way you're framing
that in the fake environment.
I think that's a really good one.
- [Gary] You know, and why...
- A lot in business too.
I mean this is why it's the most...
- Look, look.
You know where it really plays
and this is where in our little ecosystem?
You wanna talk about our kids?
You have older kids.
- [Beth] Yeah.
- If you asked me the biggest fear I have,
fake environment.
Let me tell you what's really going on.
This is just deep and I wanna get this off
'cause I'm so passionate.
This feels like the right
time to talk about it.
There are people out
there who have startups
whose daddy or mommy is
underwriting it quietly.
The only two people know
sometimes is mad and the son.
Not ever the dad knows
that they're kicking cash
to keep it alive 'cause the mom or the dad
or the kid or the boy or the girl
they all like the facade that
little Johnny's doing well.
Mom's kicking cash because
she wants her friends to think
her son or daughter is the
next Mark fucking Zucker...
I mean fake environments.
And then kids complain, you
know kids complain like,
"My parents fucked me up."
Then don't take the money.
And I'm talking about the gym pass.
Like, if you want your
parents to have no say.
A lot of times kids...
You know, I get a lot of family dynamics.
Gary, I love you, you're right.
Fuck my mom and dad, you're right.
I'm like, be careful.
Let's start over.
Are they giving you money? Yeah.
Well then they have control.
Then fuck you.
- [Beth] Yeah.
- If you wanna go to
SoulCycle every weekend
and you're taking momma's money
and you're not earning it, guess what?
Momma's in charge.
- What do people say back
to you when you say that?
- Fuck.
They're like, you know...
- They're like, you got me, is that it?
It's kind of like you got me.
- They're kind of like damn it.
I thought you were on my team.
I'm like no, no.
I'm on the team of merit.
If your parents are insecure
and are making you become an engineer
because it makes them look
good at a cocktail party,
they're bad.
If you are mad at your parents
for creating entitlement
but you're taking the cash
because you wanna go on the
cruise with your buddies
to fucking Ibiza, you're bad.
I'm in the corner of the truth.
- [Beth] Yeah.
- Got it?
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you really have grown a lot.
(laughing)
- You know what's funny?
I've just communicated a lot.
If you think about it,
in our first interactions,
I was pushing social media's
ROI in a way that nobody was.
- Yeah, I remember
meeting you over breakfast
at South by Southwest in Austin.
I think that was one of our first meetings
and just your passion
and it was like clear
you were gonna make this happen.
- 100%.
I do believe that people,
it was interesting.
I was listening to you and I
had that feeling a little bit.
There is no question.
Things that I see everyday
that I'm like, oh.
That person's legitimately
gonna will this to success.
It's starting off as a sushi restaurant
and she might sell diapers in Afghanistan
but that is going to work.
- [Beth] Yeah, yeah.
- That was a great question, Andy.
Good job.
(laughing)
- [Andy] We have a
caller I'm trying to get.
- Do it, do it.
And I'll keep you up in a little bit.
Beth, this is not...
- It's my first book.
- It is, right.
- [Beth] Yeah.
It's a lot of work.
- Interesting process.
- It was a lot of work.
I had a co-writer.
Tahl Raz was my co-writer.
So that was helpful 'cause I had a job...
- [Robotic Voice] The
number you have dialed is...
- [Andy] Trying to do it.
- Go ahead.
- No, so it was a lot of...
Because it's a very
personal book, I had to...
- [Gary] You got precious with it.
- Well I just feel exposed a bit, right?
So I'm nervous about it.
I'm nervous because I
put stuff out there that
as a reserved person it
was against my nature
in some ways to be so open about things.
I put failure in it.
So, it was a very
emotionally draining book
in that respect 'cause
I had to really dig deep
to go like what was I feeling?
Okay, you didn't really handle that well.
Like, I talk a lot in here about...
(phone ringing)
Some tension especially
with a couple people and
I had to go back, it was so easy to go,
what you're saying.
He was a jerk.
- You took it on you.
Good for you.
- But, no, like...
- Who's this?
- [Andy] This is Karin.
- Karin?
- [Karin] Hello.
- [Karin] Hello?
(phone ringing)
- Karin?
- [Karin] Hello.
- [Karin] Yes.
- This is...
Karin, this is...
Karin this is Gary Varynerchuk.
- [Karin] Oh, hello.
(Beth laughing)
- Hello.
- [Karin] Oh hi.
- I think you're watching
this right now, right?
I can hear it in the background.
- [Karin] Yeah.
- Can you lower it?
- [Karin] Oh, okay.
Yes, sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
Hang on.
Okay. I switched it off.
- Okay, great.
- [Karin] Like the phone.
Hello.
- Hello Karin.
Say hello to Beth Comstock.
- Hi Karin.
- [Karin] Hello Beth, how are you?
- Good, how are you?
- [Karin] Very good. Thank you.
- Do you have a question for us?
- [Karin] Yes.
I'm here in Vancouver Canada.
And I'm basically trying to advocate
for mothers who are professional mothers
but who have been out of the workforce for
a long period of time.
Five, 10, 15 years and
they might have been
mid-managers or senior managers
and they would like to go back to work
and now the question I have is
on a corporate management level,
because that's where I'm going next,
how do I convince somebody,
what you work at GE.
How do I go to them and say,
there's this mom who was amazing.
She doesn't have paid work experience
in the last 10 years but
before this she was brilliant.
So how do I convince
them to take a chance?
- Karin, I love this question.
And I can also tell how hard it is.
So one, thanks for putting it out there.
One, I would start with saying,
whatever has happened over the past,
it's not that you were brilliant
and then you went away 10 years
and now you have to reestablish it.
You're still brilliant.
So how do you package that?
So some part of it is
just packaging yourself.
What are some things you've been doing?
Maybe there's some things
you've been working at
at your kids' school,
at a community project
that you could start to say
I've been doing marketing or
I'm a community organizer.
So, some of it is just
packaging what you've been doing
and letting people see
those organizational skills
or those promotion skills or
operation skills that you have.
That would be the first thing.
To what Gary was saying
earlier to his team here,
I think you kinda have
to keep bugging people.
You have to sorta get in
their face a little bit
until the story we were
talking about earlier.
You gotta one, do some homework.
Do some, look for companies where you see
some of the leadership,
in your case maybe you'd
look for some women leaders
who maybe are moms and maybe
you'd find a conference
where a couple of them are speaking
and go ask them afterwards like,,
hey could I show you my resume?
Is there someone on your
team who could look at it?
So, try to do some homework
and look for people
who you think might just
have a conversation with you
and give you some feedback.
And the last thing I'd say is
I feel better about corporate,
the corporate world
that they're recognizing
that there's great talent in mothers
who have been taking care of their kids
and not in the workforce.
And so, a lot of companies
are creating job shares.
I think with this notion
of the quote gig economy,
there's a lot more happening
to give people project work.
So maybe the first thing is,
maybe your first thing
won't be to get a job there
but can you take a project on?
That would allow them to
see what you're capable of
on a project component and then it's a way
to start to get them to know you
and you to know them.
I really think that's gonna be the future
of hiring anyway where more
of us in the corporate setting
are gonna be doing these kind
of limited run assignments
to see if we wanna work together.
- [Karin] Okay.
- Karin.
I'm gonna jump in here.
Let me tell you what stands out for me.
I think you need to
focus on a couple things.
One, as somebody who's been selling things
that other people don't
wanna buy his whole life,
the biggest thing...
This is an important point
that we need to tap into, Andy.
The biggest thing that I will tell you
is do not try to sell
somebody who's not sellable.
- [Karin] Okay.
- When something that is so right
like what you're saying.
Like I've always thought I was so right
and history would prove me out right
and that's been my career.
But, the problem is that when
you're selling something early
people don't see it.
- [Beth] Right.
- You are so right.
Like, you're talking, I'm like, man.
I want the next 30 people
I hire at Vayner to be that
because managing a family
is a skill and a half
that maps so well to people.
Management is everything.
Like, I'm in.
- Yeah.
They're doing so many things at once.
- Yeah, so we've had
conversations here about this
'cause we think it's a white space.
But, I promise you that
at an enormous amount
of organizations, call it 99,
aren't interested in what you just said.
At this moment.
And I'm not trying to be Debbie Downer.
I just know the game right now.
There's a lot of pushback.
What most people do, and
whether it's 90% or 70%.
It's irrelevant.
About 99 to 70.
But I promise you it's higher than
anybody would like to think.
It's the sad truth of the
reality of the situation.
Regardless of that,
most people when they are so right
on something so right,
get ideological.
They go into I'm gonna prove to that no
that this is right and
they punch against a wall.
Versus spending all their
time to Beth's earlier point
of finding the yeses.
And by the way, Beth and
Linda Boff and Paul Markum
were my yes in 2011.
That was a big company named GE
in a world that I looked around
and they said yes to social and Vayner
and made an enormous bet on me
and so did Pepsi and Bonnet and other...
And many, many others...
I didn't spend a second and Karin,
I did not spend a second
pitching my services
to anybody that showed signals to me
that they were in the no business.
I wasn't ideological.
I went to where there was opportunity.
Beth is unbelievably right
and I will triple down on it.
More homework on the people
that are ideologically
aligned with you on
the importance of this.
Like, do not get it twisted.
It's a sad state of affairs.
She's absolutely right
that female leadership's
gonna do a better job for you.
They're gonna have more empathy.
You're gonna have a character
once in a while like me.
Cool.
But you've gotta really look for that
and you gotta look for my
content that showed you that.
I would live on LinkedIn
and watch what people
are putting out there
and then focus on 13 to 15 organizations
that have given you signals
that they're open to this
and get slowly but surely
and then when you prove
it out that it works at
you know, Google, or schmoogle,
or Corona, or wherever,
then you could start
building on that case study.
I am blown away by people
spending all their time
trying to convince the no's
because it's like a fulfilled prophecy.
- Yeah, that's such good advice.
I tried to build my reputation
as someone who was open
to anyone with a good idea.
And, I have people who would
just call me with a great,
send me a great email and
I'd say, I wanna see you.
I'm rare.
- [Gary] Me too.
- I'm rare.
But to your point, we are out there.
- 100%.
- [Karin] Okay.
- Karin, makes sense, right?
- [Karin] Yes, yes. That is so helpful.
Thank you so much.
- Thanks for watching.
- [Karin] Okay, goodbye.
- Goodbye.
- [Man] That was so awesome.
(laughing)
- What else should we cover?
What else should people
know about this book?
I really do want the
Vayner nation to go out
and pick this up.
I think this is gonna
be a dominant player.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I mean, I'm really
trying to give people
a pocket of encouragement
to just grab permission
and make change happen.
Don't wait for it.
One of my quotes that I
love in there is like,
who are you waiting for
to tell you it's okay?
Your mother...
- Did the person that you...
Did the person...
Oh, keep going.
- No, your mother.
- [Gary] Keep going.
- Your boss? Your mother? Yoda?
Right?
I mean, who are you waiting for?
You're who you're waiting for.
So, that's the basic,
and I just share little
hacks of things I did.
And things I learned.
- What was the story
in there that you said
this one was on me?
You were starting to talk
before we did the phone call
about taking ownership and it
was easy to say it was him.
Give me the act of...
- No, I mean I have a
particular chapter in there
about the last time I was at NBC
and it was a very tense time.
And, I literally had just real arguments
with one of the people I had to work with
and I shared them in there.
- [Gary] You mentioned?
- And I shared in the book.
- [Gary] The person's name?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And did they reach out to you?
- Not yet, no.
But what I had to do
was to go back and go,
put myself in his position.
Imagine him at the time.
The business wasn't doing well.
I look like a competitive threat
that had been planted from headquarters.
- [Gary] That's right.
- I was challenging kind of tradition
with the cool kid approach to digital
and I was coming in a
bit like I'm the cool kid
with all these digital tools.
Imagine that and me coming in there
and I didn't have that perspective then
and I wish I had.
So that's some of what I was trying to do.
- And for you at this point
and you've talked about it
thematically through here.
Either you're born with
it, it can develop,
but once you actually tap into empathy,
you can become unstoppable.
The reason I didn't get
mad that nobody wanted to,
and to this day the reason
I can deal with how much
pushback I get because of my,
I have to have empathy for
I have a specific personality type
that on initial consumption
is going to turn off people.
And like, by the way, I need to say this.
I wish I didn't.
You know?
And I know, it's funny you reacted.
My team, no, no, no, listen.
You get all the pros of being a character
but what you lose is you start
to become disproportionately
underestimated in your intellect.
Nothing is ever talked
about how smart I am.
Like, this is why...
- But you couldn't have
built what you've built
without being smart.
- Yeah, but it takes a
while for people to wrap
their head around that, right?
That's exactly right.
But it takes time, plus
you have to build it.
So that means you have to eat
shit during the game, right?
You know, to have the
appetite to eat shit.
Like, to me I like being underestimated.
- But doesn't it give you a
bit of a competitive advantage
when people underestimate you?
- Beth, it's the greatest
gift of all time.
I manipulate my, I continue
to suppress my own success
'cause I think it's that
big of an advantage.
- Yeah, I think I can relate.
I think as a woman in business
I had something similar in the sense of
I had to work extra hard.
- [Gary] 100%.
- But I also think as a creative person...
- That as well.
- I had to fight against
that but being a woman,
I was perhaps allowed to
be a bit more creative.
And I think sometimes
certainly in business world,
creative men may have a harder time
expressing their creativity.
- I think that's right.
You know, it's funny.
I looked at a picture...
You know, it's really interesting.
Because I'm an immigrant.
Because I wasn't born in this country.
Because boy, being
Jewish in eastern Europe
post-World War II, my
family's stories are just
unbearable.
10 years in jail.
Like, real shit.
I've, you know, but it's interesting.
I've always kind of leaned there.
I gotta tell you, being an F student,
like, I tap so heavy
into the underdog thing
and it just makes so much sense to me.
And actually what's so amazing
is the internet for real.
No, I don't think we've
quantified this yet.
It's going to bring such
an advantage to people
that deal with adversity on the come up
and it's such a
disadvantage to entitlement.
Fake environments, you're in trouble.
Adversity, you're gonna win.
'Cause the platform rewards merit.
It's gonna be very interesting.
It's gonna get real interesting.
- Yeah, well I think it's interesting.
I mean meritocracy is not real...
It depends on who set the standards.
And I think I've just clued into that
in the past few years
just as you see that.
I mean, certainly the Me Too movement.
Women have been seeing this for a while.
Who set the standards?
I once did a panel with
somebody out of Silicon Valley
and he said, you know,
"We're not gonna lower our standards
and that's why we don't
have any more women."
And I was like who set the standards?
How do you know the
standards couldn't be higher
if you had more women?
- This is why,
I tell all my, anybody who
feels that they're being not,
not at the seat at the table,
AKA, anybody who isn't
an old white male, right?
I basically say the
same thing to them like,
fuck them.
Don't play their game.
Go create your own fucking game.
You own it.
The internet, go.
Go, like, right?
Like, you're not getting money
from venture capitalists?
Go get money from high
net worth individuals.
- Yeah, yeah.
Makes you more creative.
- Don't play the game.
- [Beth] Yeah, yeah.
- Like, back to like some themes here.
Vayner Media was built on the fact that
I didn't play the agency game.
Like, I just didn't play it.
- No, it's driven you, I think.
- 100%.
You know, 100...
- I love that about you
that you're still trying
to disrupt and there's
not much left to disrupt
for some of 'em but you're, right?
That you're still, like that hunger like,
I know a different and
better way to do it.
- 100% because it's very real.
Right?
Like you're on the right side of history.
And because I'm building
this machine for myself.
- Yeah, I remember you like,
when you were trying to
get more into advertising,
you were like,
"Just give me a shot. Just give me a shot.
Our creative's gonna be the best
and if it's not, we're gonna come back
and make it the best."
And you did.
Like, you just kept working it.
I don't think people appreciate
that is what it takes.
- I think that's right.
I think, you know, I'm so glad...
I'm gonna wrap up here in a minute.
I'm just so grateful that you
told that Ted Turner story.
You can't imagine.
I'm gonna clip that.
I think you're gonna
change a lot of people...
I don't think, you know, I
have a very deep understanding
of what's going on with
communication right now.
I don't think you understand.
I'm telling you you don't.
You're gonna be so pumped
'cause we're gonna talk
about this in nine years.
You don't know what that did.
- [Beth] Wow. Okay.
- I'm telling you about this
30 year old thing, Beth.
Like, I'm telling you.
There's been such a broken narrative.
That's so interesting, yeah.
And, I just pulled some photos of myself
when I was 30 'cause there is
something in my head about,
that was that story but it's
interesting you're saying
that now.
For me, now that you're
saying that I'm thinking
30 was a big year for me.
- And you know, we got unlucky,
and I'll say, it's funny.
I wish you were 31 or 32.
I don't wanna even narrow in on that.
It's this.
Almost everybody in this
entitled environment
thinks that they have to
have everything figured out
at 26, 29, 32, 31.
Meanwhile, nobody has
anything figured out ever.
- No, I mean I was...
By 30, I had been married
and divorced and had a kid
and was working on my second marriage
and on my way to a second kid
and I didn't know what
my job was gonna be.
I came from a small town
where we didn't have
a lot of connections, right?
I mean, aside from my
dad with the producer
with the molar and grip hold.
But, you know, you have to get out
and just try things and
kind of be resilient.
- Love it.
Beth.
- Thank you for this.
Thanks for all the support.
- Beth, you get to ask the question...
In this show, the guest gets
to ask the question of the day.
So, what's fun about the
question of the day is
we're gonna get thousands of responses.
Now this is where you can
go theoretical, selfish,
here's what I mean by that.
You can ask a question where
you can get a lot of insight.
There's a lot of people watching.
There'll be a lot of answers
so I tend to like to
use it for focus groups.
You can ask a random thing
that's just been on your mind.
It could be about something
that's happening in culture.
Like, on Netflix or on
your app or about the book
or the concept or anything you want.
What is your question of the day?
- I'm gonna go back to
the question you got.
What do we need to do to
push for more creative
problem solving in the world?
What are your ideas?
Who's doing it well?
I'm just eager to learn
people who are doing it well.
- [Andy] You guys wanna mention
they can answer the question
of the day on Twitter.
- Cool.
- [Andy] 'Cause this live
podcast is sometimes.
- Awesome.
Please answer that question on Twitter.
And, Beth, I'm super
excited about this book.
I'm so proud of you.
- Thank you. Thanks.
- I was close to the
process of you debating it
and doing it and dah, dah, dah, dah.
Thank you so much.
You're a real pleasure.
You keep asking questions.
We'll keep answering them.